hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today we have the new event fangs of the
other world we're gonna be talking about
everything that is in that event so
you're kept up today with everything
that's happening it's as long as like to
me if you're doing Joe subscribe for new
I cover the informational site a
foreigner that being the balance changes
they hear updates the patch notes and
the leaks if I'm to be kept up today
with everything happening within the
world of foreigner and never miss out on
an update if they're subscribed the
channel with that let's get started with
today's video so as per usual with this
stuff I will be live streaming on Twitch
my twitch will be down in the
description down below so if you want to
be playing or while yours is downloading
you want to watch me stream I would love
if you guys would come by if not I
totally understand yeah like I said it's
gonna be down on the description down
below if you want to check the link for
that follow so you know solve all that
beautiful stuff for yes so let's get
into today's video there's going to be a
new arcade quest and a couple more
coming in the late weeks we already
understand that arcade quests come by
the week so it's obvious that that would
be a thing so there's a lot of marching
fire cots and there if you fancy that
community owners are gonna be consisting
of an emblem as well some bonus steal so
if you're down to get some of that juicy
stuff you can and also there's going to
be a new game-mode the spooky slashers
game-mode which we'll cover later in the
video so no worries as usual the
background for the game is spooky themed
with some classic VHS effects and a
giant green moon in the back I'm going
to be the same for the face off screen
although they didn't show it on streem
you could pretty much assume that that's
going to be very similar for the
soldiers they're going to be vampires
oneís and werewolves although they kind
of said that they were vampires kind of
ghouls I'm gonna go around for the
ghouls territory though cuz they're
starting to look like them a lot more
the more I look at them so those are
gonna be the minion themes for this type
of season remember so the werewolves are
gonna be Vikings oneis are gonna be
samurai and the ghouls are gonna be for
the Knights
the emblem outline is really cool this
time around as well it's got this red
and black theme so all you have to do is
just get that by logging on anywhere
between the event and you will get that
for your account they never mentioned it
but judging from the music they played
during the stream it's probably going to
be that same excellent Halloween music
we had last year and then the year
before as well so I've always been a big
fan of that music so it's really nice to
see that coming back if that's supposed
to be true we also have some cosmetics
as well so we have a new effect called
the a trophic ritual I believe that's
pronounced to wear some spooky candles
come up and some blue smoke appear right
where the candles are it's an idol emo
in effect as well and it's also lootable
up of that we also have a bat
which pretty much matches the candle
effect of that blue smoke as well as an
ornament all basically sounding the same
I'm not gonna be able to pronounce this
so don't bother me asking but if you see
the app terrific I believe the name is
called then you basically got one of the
new items in the new event which is
really cool and honestly kind of not
really a big fan in the ornament in the
battle off at this time around but
that's just my opinion it looks cool
though so if any of you want to grab
that of course just we'll cover that on
how you can get that stuff as well later
in the video a little bit of a switch up
instead of having a bunch of illustrious
outfits or you know one perfection or
whatever it happens to be we actually
have 200 serious outfits this time but
they're going to be for every faction
this time we have ghoulish fate and
lichen so this is more of like a team
ghoul versus team werewolf situation and
any faction can get these so Knights
Viking Samurai and wolven will be able
to get both of these illustrious outfits
kind of basically to sell selling to
your team and telling the other team as
well what kind of team you're on
personally I like both of them I'm gonna
have to decide but yeah they're going to
be the same normal price as any other
illustrious outfit but since there's two
of course gonna have to pay double if
you want to get both I definitely keep
that in mind yeah it's really cool that
we're getting to this time for all for
everybody as opposed to just one
perfection because I think that's really
nice - everyone's getting an opportunity
to use them next we have the executions
and that's 10k steel and notice how I
set executions because we actually have
four and it's also a faction based so we
have this we have the revenant Slayer
which is the night execution so any
character that you play that as a knight
will be able to use this execution it's
some type of vampire sequence kind of
holy stuff we got going here personally
probably my favorite and the entire one
out of all four of these for the Viking
we have this type of werewolf kill
execution now of course this is gonna be
for all the Viking heroes so no samurai
will enter tonight's are gonna be able
to use this pretty Samurai we have a
salt circle surrounding an Oni demon and
then he's throwing a lot more salt on
the demon to finally eliminate it so
that's really cool so once again your
samurai character definitely pick that
up and if you use a woolen character you
have the idea you have the opportunity
to do a possession with a purified charm
this has to do with a lot of the history
in the ancient yeah the ancient history
and the lore and stuff in the backstory
of the Chinese culture I don't really
know what it means
but I guess the bouncing zombie
demon-possession thing is actually very
common and what they believe in and
stuff so this actually fits like
historically it looks kind of funny in
my opinion but I still think it's pretty
cool so obviously if you have a woollen
character definitely go pick that up for
45000 steel you can get a giant bundle
from October 17th which is today from
November 4th that is the time that it's
going live and you'll be able to buy all
the goodies we just mentioned for a
cheaper price which is always nice I
believe it's 45,000 steel like I stated
I usually like to go and get all this
stuff first and then right when the
event is over because the event actually
ends on November 1st but you have about
three days to buy the bundle just in
case you missed out on stuff so if I
ever need to buy the bundle I usually
buy it when the event is fully over
because then you're just because what
the the way that the bundles work is
that if you get one of the items like
the weapons of the effects then the
price actually drops down so you don't
have to pay double for the same thing
obviously we're gonna have weapons this
event and I'm actually really excited to
see how these are for the weapons we
have a nice black and red color scheme
as you can see most of the night weapons
have some demon or werewolf type of
style with it somewhere on the weapon
looks really cool Centurion probably is
my favorite throughout this entire event
honestly fraud all of these weapons I'm
pretty sure I'm a big fan of Centurion
as well as the up-and-coming Highlander
one you'll see the gargoyle shoes on
gladiator is pretty cool personally I'm
not a big - I'm not too big of a fan but
some other people might enjoy that lob
ringers I think is nice and kind of fits
him I but I specifically think that the
black prior weapon fits BP the most just
the way you know his edgy phases and
everything like that I think the black
prior weapon really does fit his
character where I was also about the Oni
and the demons are anusha has the
standard two different color handles I'm
not really sure why that's a trend for
him but maybe our Musa Mane's really
enjoy that on top of that Nobu sees
weapons have always looked nice so
nothing has changed there of course
she's got some solid weapons
shinobi has some knife serrated blades
on both of his which looks really cool
he told Kari is probably the creepiest
one I've seen in this faction and
personally as I stated Centurions my
favorite but he topiaries is definitely
the creepiest one obviously it fits her
character she's always creepy looks like
she smoked a pack a day for 30 years but
you can also notice as well in the
background
that some of the for the weapons and
stuff is that in the back there's the
new map with no worries we'll get into a
little bit that soon for just a little
side note just the case you were
wondering for the Vikings it's all about
the werewolf's which makes sense
you got loads of designs here based on
where werewolf looks which look really
cool with the gem placement everywhere
serrated tips for weapons like I told
you Highlanders got the biggest [ __ ]
sword in the game and he's got the
deadliest looking sword as well in this
game it looks like there's blood on the
serrated tips there there's that demon
in the middle which looks like I has
blood coming out of it same with black
priors absolutely really deadly I don't
know if the red on the weapons is going
to change depending on the color that
you have like me how the the ornaments
used to do that too with the gems and
stuff I don't actually know if that's
going to change I kind of hope that
because I actually kind of like that
it's red because it makes it look like
actual blood it'd be kind of weird if it
was like yellow then it'd kind of be
kind of creepy like you're eating a
bumblebee or something kind of weird and
then lastly we have the Wulin which is
all about possession those purity charms
like I said from the execution I've got
some small demons on some handles as
well what some nice yin and yang on the
new show hook blades not too much crazy
stuff for the Wulin but honestly still
really good weapons the design team
never really flops when it comes to
weapons in this game I believe if they
always look really good every season
every event but as usual some of the
weapons are going to be ok or maybe not
too great but I think just like the last
seasonal event we had most of the
characters are gonna be very happy with
the weapons are getting so if you
there's like a 90% chance the character
you are playing is probably going to get
a good weapon for them so real quick we
have a quick recap but that's about what
is lootable what is not lootable how to
get all that stuff because that is super
important and a lot of people ask me in
my video so it's a recap we have the
lootable x' and the non notables and the
non Blue Devils aka the unlockables
those are the execution and the
illustrious outfits those are not
lootable
they are unlockable meaning you have to
buy them with steel and there's no other
way to get them you have to buy them
with steel the weapons are also Lua
the weapons are lootable and they're
lootable depending on what character you
play in that match so if you play as
Highlander there's a chance that
Highlander weapons will drop you will
not get a shaman a hito kiri
or Berserker a Valkyrie anything like
that it'll only be
and her weapons if you play as
Highlander that game and then the
ornament the battle outfit and the
effect are all going to be lootable
randomly which means every time you
finish a game you will get a random
effect for a random character so even if
you're playing somebody like warden you
might get the heat soak eerie effect so
you definitely have to keep grinding for
that which is why I will definitely be
making a video either tomorrow or the
day after and actually not forget this
time on how to get this stuff the
fastest because of course there's so
much [ __ ] with this event that everyone
needs to get all the goodies and as well
for that effect obviously it comes in
Idol emo and execution when you get the
effect it doesn't come with all three
you might just get the idol you might
just get the emote you have to get all
three if you do want to and now onto the
maps and you notice I said Maps because
that means we actually have two this
time it used to be we usually got one
new map but now we actually have two one
of them I believe is this is called
overwatch it's I've played this game for
almost 2000 hours you would think I
would know the map names but I really
don't I believe this is overwatch and
there's a lot of changes with this we
got ectoplasm dripping from the wall we
got a giant black hole in the sky
pumpkins on the statues or four green
flames everywhere
don't worry only the flames that will
hurt you in the game are the orange like
actual fire the green flames are
according to the devs magical so they
won't actually do any damage but yeah
that's what I noticed and for the second
map they aren't gonna show it but it was
the one that was during the weapon
showcase someone's gonna have to remind
me in the comments what that map is
called once again I don't remember what
it's called at all but it's in the it's
in the trailer and it's in the weapon
showcase so those are the two maps the
one that was in the trailer slash weapon
showcase that I showed and then also the
one we're just looking at now overwatch
those are gonna be the two new event
maps for this new game-mode and for that
new game-mode it's gonna be called
spooky slashers the game-mode is told by
the developers is a revision on the
endless March game-mode from last year
which is really nice it is a four view
for Dominion where you can only cap a
and C for 200 points and then no points
a second the minions are going to be
hard points hard points and soft points
are a little bit different hard points
mean as soon as you earn those points
they can never be taken away from you
like killing an enemy for example in
regular Dominion and soft points are our
points that you can lose if you lose
something like losing an objective in
Dominion so those 100 points you get
from a Dominion capture you can lose
those if they if the enemy captures it
back very similar to this so killing
minions rewards you hard points that you
can never lose and reward the fastest
amount of points depending on you know
the buff that you're gonna be receiving
and that was a really good way to
increase your overall score it's about 5
points per minion and they hurt a lot I
believe they're actually pikemen as the
developer said and they what and the big
issue is that they also hit really hard
so every time you capture a point you
gain this damage buff which allows you
to do more damage to the minion and also
take less damage from them and so it's
actually a fair and even fight and
according to the developer that if you
don't have the boost from capping the
point or at least sitting on the point
then you probably don't want to be
fighting the minions at all so I don't
know if these guys are gonna like to
shot you I hope that's not the case but
we'll have to see when we get into the
game so yeah and that's really the big
revision of the endless March game-mode
I kind of like this I've always been a
big fan of endless March so spooky
slasher is gonna be really cool as well
and yeah other than that guys that's
gonna be the end of the beta hopefully
guys did enjoy as always like I said my
torch will be down in the description if
you guys want to follow that and watch
them with the stream for a little bit
while the game is downloading or maybe
you're at work or something like that I
would highly recommend you come to the
stream we're gonna have a lot of fun
there
it's just for a couple hours they'll
hang out chill out all that good stuff
yeah let me know what you guys think
about this new event there is there
isn't going to be a dead stream next
week it might just be some patch notes
or some small stuff but I know the week
after that on the 31st we got some
really juicy info on the reveal stream
for the season 12 character which I'm
super excited about
if we stay tuned for all that stuff as
always like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe for new I covered there the
informational SATA fauna that being the
balance changes to here updates the
patch notes and the leaks if when we
catch this day with everything happening
there within the world of foreigner and
never miss out on an update deaf estate
subscribe the channel and I guys take
care have a girls today hope you guys
enjoyed the event hope you guys come to
the stream as well peace out
you